right now metro searching for sexual
assault victims from
four different suspects police say
multiple assaults happened in
areas that you're about to see right
here on your screen they say in some
cases here the victims were sex workers
while others were in areas where sex
work is known to happen
eight news now reporter kate houston
live from west tropicana and dean martin
drive where police say
three of these sexual assaults happened
kate
yes police say that each of these four
men are considered
violent predators and that some of these
cases have similarities
where that the crimes occurred in areas
where it is known
that prostitution happens now police say
that the men believe that these women
would be easy targets
here are some pictures of those four men
on your screen they have been arrested
and it's believed that there are
additional victims detectives are asking
for them to come forward with any
information
i did speak to danielle staple today
with the rape crisis center who says
violence against sex workers has always
been an ongoing problem
in most situations staples says sexual
predators will focus on victims with
many vulnerabilities
and individuals who may have less
credibility in the criminal justice
system
when it comes to prostitution she says
that violence can be taken to the next
level
especially if money is involved when
an individual feels like
they are exchanging money for what their
what they're getting
they they take that human element out of
it and what we have to remember is this
is a human being
that is involved in this and um you know
it doesn't take away
the element of consent or having that
ability
to agree to you know certain things and
not agree to certain things
staple adds that no matter who you are
or what you do
no one is deserving of being sexually
assaulted and it is not
their fault metro police are now
searching for other victims in the area
they say this investigation will go at
the victim's pace
when the victim is comfortable with the
investigation only then will it move
forward
police say that one of the sexual
assaults happened after a man
met up with a woman on an online dating
platform